hi my name is Gocha converse cow I am a
kernel developer advil from research and
I'm going to talk about quantities in
probability and statistics
so this is the this is the plan for the
talk I will talk about a bit of the
quantity data and descriptive measures
then about quantity distribution the
solvers in our framework derive
distributions estimation and then do a
little fun part at the end so the
quantity data so when we measure objects
basically most of these measurements
would not make sense without units so
basically the units come you know in the
data naturally they would say all around
us so as an example here i'll have the
hundreds the distance to from sound to
the for the stars for the hundred meter
stars and as you can see the data comes
in the light years so if I extract the
distances I can have a histogram of
these distances I can also calculate the
basic descriptive statistics so the mean
median mean marks and put it in a table
form and they come here to us in the
same units as the data so in the light
years and also for example we can find a
distance to defer the nearest star so
that's what we had all the you know data
in the same units we can also have data
with mixed units okay so this is a
simple example where we have meters Fiji
arts centimeters and they the question
of course is if I have this data which
is much bigger and you know comes in all
mixed units whether they all make sense
in the sense that they would come from
the same type of measurements so it's
just the same you know the length units
over the time units so we have a in the
info for men which we have you know
compatible you need cube oops it's good
to evaluate all the cells from the
beginning so you can check if the all
units come from the same type and then
it makes sense to you compute for
example some means it makes sense to
convert their data to some other unit or
to the standard you need to have them
unified
we work for this so quantity or a
quantity array it's an object when we
would like to store you know bigger
amount you know more data with with
units so more quantities than justice
four or five and i have here an example
when you just simulate random variate
from the binomial distribution so we
have bunch of vectors and what we can do
we would like to say okay my first
component components of this vector so
in meters the Second Coming pounds so
this is how we can you know store them
in a form of quantity array with this
units for each component and again we
can compute the descriptive measures and
look at them the meters and in the
pounds for each component okay quantity
distribution so when we have when we
have data that comes in units we would
like to be able to have in models in a
way that we have the distribution of
these quantities and this is where we
introduced a new object quantity
distribution that models the
distribution of magnitudes and also
stores the units for the quantities so
this is a quantity distribution with
magnitudes that are exponential that are
that follow exponential distribution and
units these seconds and you can see that
it's type sets differently that the
typesetting of the unities is special
here so this is our standard unit time
setting and then it makes sense to run
the same operation sis of quantity so
extract the quantity magnitude which
will be our exponential distribution or
extract the unit which is the seconds we
can do the same conversion as we could
do it on data so we can convert the
distribution to the quantity
distribution to a different units and we
can simulate from this distribution and
so the single simulation will give us a
quantity or the appropriate units and
when we have more than one the return
output is in the form of quantity array
for this and then we can have a
histogram over the South would we can
compute also the CDF another
functions of the distribution at a given
point and notice that the input here at
the point is actually a quantity and
then we can compute mean and variance of
the distribution and it also comes in
the corresponding quantities of the
corresponding units so the variance here
second squared okay this is an example
for a multivariate case so when we had
the situation with the quantities where
we want to have a say kilograms and
meters for one component and the other
and other components or different units
for different components we can also
introduce this as a quantity
distribution and also what I would like
to show here is that if the quantities
as parameters make sense as inputs to
distribution we can input quantities
directly into the distribution so this
is by normal distribution when the first
vector is a vector of means in the
second is a vector of standard
deviations so we would have the issue
that the first component of this random
variable here would be the meters the
second would be the kilograms and the
last thing post is the correlation
coefficient which is dimensionless so
there is no unit associated with this
and then if this assignment is input of
quantities as parameters for the
distribution makes sense and upon
evaluation it's going to give us a
quantity distribution input in in that
way so then you basically know that that
that was the correct it's a correct
assignment of quantities we can compute
the mean variance of the properties for
the distribution the same way moments
and cumulants and again it's going to
calculate the proper unit for each
property simulate so the single
observation is just a vector and then
multiple observations we're gonna have
the quantity array we can plot the
density histogram 3d in this case
because two dimensional data and also we
can extract the distribution of the
height which is in this case we're going
to extract the marginal distribution for
the first component and it's gonna give
us the corresponding quantity
distribution of the chorus
units okay so our quantity distribution
and quantities we're going to work in in
our solvers so the main servers are
probability an expectation and also
their corresponding partners and
probability and expectation and so I'm
going to again use this height weight
distribution here and so showed before
that we can use the marginal so I have
the weight distribution which is
univariate I can find the expectation of
the weight in pounds so what is here
it's the unit convert as an expression
for the expectation and then use the
distribution of the weight but also what
we can do instead of converting we can
specify target units in expectation and
we can ask for the expectation of this
distribution in the target units and
it's going to automatically convert
behind the scenes to give us the answer
in the in the target units another
example is to find out expected absolute
deviation from the mean for the height
also we can compute conditional
probability so this is probability that
a person's height is over 1.75 meters
given that the way it is about 72
kilograms so another example let's say
that we have some constant which in this
case it's the rates production of apples
in Poland and that's some quantity so if
you hover then we actually can see that
it's short tons per year and we're going
to assume maybe that this production is
distributed according to Rayleigh
distribution so if we input the right
directly in rayleigh we're gonna get the
quantity distribution we can plot the
PDF and then can for example ask what's
the probability that this daily up the
daily apple production according to this
distribution exceeds weights of 15
International Space Station's point 6 we
produce lots of apples in Poland
so yeah okay derive distributions will
also accept the quantity distribution as
the input and also I would like to point
out the quantity distribution on its own
is the type of a derived distribution is
why I already talked about the marginal
distribution that was the case where we
extracted the weight distribution or
hide from our by normal distribution I
will have example here here for the
transform distribution and I would like
to say that each of this derived
distributions reference page will have
some examples of quantities or quantity
distribution if you want to have a look
in more detail so here I'm going back to
this height weight distribution and we
know that that the body mass index is
weight in kilograms divided over the
square height in meters so because my
distribution here it's a meters
kilograms you can find the distribution
of the vmi directly from applying the
transform distribution with this simple
expression and with our height weight
distribution so that's again a quantity
distribution because we brought
quantities the unit changed because of
the operation applied on the random
variables we can find the numerically
the mean of this distribution and then
we can find the sample and find a
histogram for the density function so
that would illustrate the distribution
ok of the of the BMI and this is of
course for the assumed population ok so
we assume that the population is from
this by normal distribution if you want
to figure out you know more one would
have to go and find out for each country
or globally and such so the assumption
here it's somewhat random okay the next
thing are to do when we have lots of
quantic data would be to find models for
those and we have really two ways to
find models it's a parametric models or
non parametric models so I'm going to
first talk about parametric models and
example here's the temperatures in
Chicago for 2015
what I have here is a is a kind of
commented out code how to obtain the
time series that i am using you know
here as the assignment so it takes a
little while so i just have them you
know already in but if you would like to
repeat this calculation this is the code
and i'm going to have this you know also
some other commented code later through
the talk this is how it looks like on a
histogram for the sake of the
distributions we don't really care about
the timestamp so what we really want are
the values so you can extract the values
from these temperatures and this is
given as a quantity array so the
connection here is in the sense that if
we have long enough big enough time
series with quantities then internally
it's going to also use quantity or right
to store that for you know if the the
units are for example the same because
it's more economical in that way so we
have a quantity right and now to find a
parametric estimate for the skew normal
distribution that's just my choice
looking at the histogram so what happens
is that I I gave only skew normal
distribution but my data came in units
and so what we have as the output here
is a quantity distribution with the
units that are taken from the data but
what we can also do is to ask for the
target distributions on the output so
the second second call here it's the
total estimated distribution is we've
directly find quantity distribution of
the degrees Fahrenheit and so the
conversion happens here behind the
scenes and the model it's in the inner
fire hider then you can convert the
first model from Celsius to Fahrenheit
to kind of check that we get the same
thing going okay nonparametric
estimation so we are still on these
temperatures in Chicago so I'm just
gonna recall we have the time series we
have the values and an example of the
nonparametric estimator is a smooth
colonel distribution and it just works
with this quantity theta and then we can
plot above the histogram and then
of models the the quantity distribution
on the skew normal and a smooth colonel
estimate on this another example for the
nonparametric estimation here is the
wind speeds in Chicago for over two
years so you can see again the commented
out code how to get this from the word
data and I have the wings in the time
series and then I'll extract the values
so I have the quantity array and what we
would like to do is now how to use this
to use the non parametric model for the
wind data and the nonparametric you know
toward the model for the turning power
output as a function of the wind speed
to find the average power output for
this type of turbine turbine so find the
model then defined the function here
which is interpolation that's again it's
using the some kind of units we have the
meters seconds and the output in
kilowatts and then find an expectation
on the touring function on my random
variable which is distributed as the the
smooth colonel estimate ok so the an
interesting example at the end is the
wind chill index and as we know the wind
chill oh I don't know I'm like little
weather aficionado but when she'll
basically takes into account the
temperatures and the winds so what I
have here it's again commented out how
to get the data but it's a temporal data
for 16 winters in in Chicago and winters
as you can see I actually took it from
the first of December to the last of
March these are the dates and what I
want here it's to store it as a temporal
data because I have just the part you
know of the of the year you know for
each for each each each winter so I
don't want to necessarily interpolate
between each winters so that's why each
year is its own puff and that's why I'm
using temporal data not time series in
this case so this is how it looks like
and then we want
we want to extract the values and then
join them into a single quantity array
because we want to look at them as one
Global winter that's the histogram and
I'm gonna do the same thing with the
wind speeds so I have the temporal data
16 winters in Chicago okay this is the
least plot extract so this is the
histogram for the wind speeds okay so
right now what are we going to do that's
kind of a random choice in a way but I
would like to have the nonparametric
estimate for the winter temperature so
just go with the smooth Colonel
distribution and have the parametric
dispara metric estimation for the wind
so I will just go with the viable that
looks no more less reasonable to see if
this actually this estimates make sense
gonna plot the pdfs against the
histograms so the density histograms so
looks ok ok so my use dose so now
windshield there is a formula for the
windshield that you know text into
account the temperature and the wind
speed and what it also requires is that
in this formula that the temperatures
come in degrees Fahrenheit and then the
wind speed comes in the miles per hour
and what we have in our data you can
also see on the on this plots here on
the histograms is that the temperatures
comes in celsius and the wind's coming
in km/h so this is when we look at at
this input here of transform
distribution we see that we are asking
for the quantity magnitude and then we
specify the units in which we want this
quantity magnitude so what it does it
automatically it's going to convert
first convert the variable or the
quantity to this unit and then extract
the new magnitude that would be
corresponding to the magnitude in this
unit so we know our wing distribution
and temperature distribution so we
define the transform distribution and we
can check that it's actually well
defined and then we can ponder about how
cold the winters in Chicago are
because this is the this is we we
generate the sample from this wind chill
distribution and we create a smooth
histogram and you can see that most of
the effective temperatures are below
below zero okay so anybody from Chicago
okay so that concludes my talk there's a
time for questions and you know also I
would like to advertise related talks on
either date visualization later today
and then what's new in probability and
statistics tomorrow morning and then I
are going to give another talk on the
time series processing tomorrow in the
afternoon so thank you and if there are
any questions happy
[Applause]